Namotasa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodasa Namotasa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodasa Namotasa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
I wanted to bring all the teachings a little bit together for you using a schema that the Buddha himself seems to have liked very much in fact he said until he'd understood the world this way he hadn't attained the unsurpassed perfect enlightenment so these three moments are important
They're translated as gratification, danger and escape.
And I'll read the discourse.
It's only a little thing.
O monks, I set out seeking the gratification in the world.
Whatever gratification there is in the world, that I have found.
I have clearly seen with wisdom just how far the gratification in the world extends.
I set out seeking the danger in the world, whatever danger there is in the world that I found.
I have clearly seen with wisdom just how far the danger in the world extends.
I set out seeking an escape from the world, whatever escape there is from the world that I have found.
I have clearly seen with wisdom how far the escape from the world extends.
And then to complement that in another discourse, he says, If monks, there were no gratification in the world, beings would not become enamoured with the world.
But it is because there is gratification in the world, beings become enamoured with it.
If there were no danger in the world, beings would not become disenchanted with the world.
But because there is danger in the world, beings become disenchanted with it.
and if there were no escape from the world beings could not escape from it but as there is an escape from the world beings can escape from it so this little schema gratification danger
and escape so none of this will come to you as a surprise it's what you've been sort of listening to all the time you've been here so this word gratification I looked it up you see because I think it's a good translation I tended to use the word satisfaction
but Bhikkhu Bodhi uses this word gratification I mean he does translate this particular Pali word with it but I think it's actually a better word in a way some ways anyway than satisfaction and I looked it up in the dictionary and he gave two examples she was gratified to see the shock in Jim's face and one that shouldn't surprise us
a thirst for sexual gratification so this word gratification I think has a slightly stronger meaning than satisfaction it suggests that sort of compulsive behaviour or a sort of demanding nature about the desire that we have and so I just think it's probably a slightly better word for us than satisfaction
Let me just, just a minute, I think there's another discourse there.
I'm going to have to read out, maybe I've got a few words, just a minute.
Yeah.
So now if we go back to the Buddha's own particular, you know, life story, there is that time, there's a little incident which comes up when he's, you know, having a good time, sort of sex, drugs and rock and roll, and he's just had a party, and he wakes up in the middle of the night and he sees all these men and women, all disheveled and saliva dripping from their...
he goes into great detail of how disgusting it was and it's that when he wakes up from the gratification that he's had from the party before so there's something about the search for gratification in the sensual world now why is it that we seek happiness there why is that?
See, there's no denial on the Buddha's part that there is gratification in the world.
I mean, there is gratification in ice cream and Costa coffee and all those things that we enjoy.
So there is gratification.
It's not that he denies that.
It would be foolish of him to do so.
And what is it that draws us to that then?
Why is it that we seek it there?
So if we go back a little bit into the sequence of our psychology, remember that we're born into this frame, we're born into this body.
And right from the beginning, you know, we're seeking milk because it's nice to taste and it comforts us.
Seek the touch of our mothers.
so there's an immediate connection right there even in the womb they say with the voice of your mother and things like that where that unborn and the born child finds pleasure and this pleasure isn't just physical is it?
it's actually an emotional well-being a well-being of being protected and of being close to some other being
So it's right there at the beginning of our experience, I think.
Now, it shouldn't be strange for us to realize or to accept that right there, even though it's not an intellectual thing, there's an immediate, there's a total identity with that experience.
There's an identity with it.
I mean, obviously the child's not saying, this is me.
It's just the way they experience life.
It's a total identity with what they are experiencing.
And I think that goes on.
I would say an ordinary person would say that they are what they experience in that total identity way.
What we tend to do, isn't it, is to try and develop comfort around us.
We want to be comfortable.
Even in our sitting posture, if it gets a bit comfortable, there's that urge to move.
If you watch yourself watching TV sometimes, there's a shuffle here and there.
As soon as it becomes slightly uncomfortable, we move the body.
Even at that sort of very basic physical level, we're always trying to be comfortable.
and when it comes to the more delightful things what we eat and our friendships and all that then there of course there's an added factor of a real delight there's loveliness in life, there's beauty in life there's all the things that we enjoy all these things the Buddha wouldn't have denied there is gratification
there is gratification so if you go through the whole gamut of your experiences in life where you've been happy from just ordinary basic things like eating to lovely times in relationships and being out in the country and listening to beautiful music and in the meditation sometimes these beautiful states of mind arise
all that is given they're going to come hopefully till we die it's not that we're going to disappear because we meditate I hope not so there's always that part of life which gives us comfort, pleasure, joy all those things
And even in our meditation, you know, we're trying to develop these factors of enlightenment to the point where they are just the way we are.
So there is that calmness and there is that equanimity and openness.
And what that means, of course, is there's no fear.
It's fear what stops us being open, isn't it?
and there's just an attention, a quiet attention to things and then there's the four great Brahmavihāras the dwelling place of the Brahmās, the great gods perhaps better understood as the illimitables love, compassion, joy and peace so that's the Buddha mind or the Buddha heart shall we say is always in that sort of state
I think sometimes we get the impression through the coolness of vipassana meditation that you end up being sort of soulless or emotionless a little bit like a dried prune I suppose but very wise well I mean it isn't like that is it the Buddha says he feels joyful, he feels happy, he feels compassionate
so his experience of life at the emotional level is always in these lovely beautiful states always in these beautiful states but somehow he's not fooled by it he's not in this sense he's not gratified he's not gratified so what is it that makes this gratification in the joys and pleasures of life gratifying
unsatisfactory not in the end gratifying so basically very simple isn't it the fact they arise and pass away just when you think you've got everything sorted it chucks a spanner and that's the end of it you try and build up a life which is meaningful and fulfilling good job and relationship and all that and then
your partner dies or they leave or the job suddenly disappears so you can't there's nowhere you can sort of rest I love I love the sayings of Jesus on that you know the birds have their nests and the foxes their holes but the son of man has nowhere to put his head and I think that's it isn't it there's nowhere there's nowhere in this world that a human being is going to be is going to be comfortable in that total way
And then when we come to investigate the psychology around pleasure, then we see all these downsides, the frustration, because of the attachment that you've built to it, because of the dependency on what's giving you happiness, there comes that frustration when you can't get it.
And there's the fear of losing it.
all the insurance that we have to buy in order just in case we do lose it we can buy another one and then there's the grief of course when you do lose it so there's a whole messy psychology in the aftermath of having indulged in something that's very pleasurable or joyful and
And that sort of connection, that identity, you see, is the root cause, isn't it?
It's because I'm saying I am, you know, I am or I have.
There's that peculiar connection with things that we have, which is very subtle, but it manifests mainly in these negative emotions and that indulgence, right?
So it's catching that, it's understanding that, that we begin to see the danger.
See, there's the danger of it.
In fact, these things hurt.
And then, having seen that danger, one seeks for the escape.
So that's the Buddha.
So he saw the danger of the emptiness, the vacuity of sensual pleasure.
It wasn't going anywhere.
that's when he leaves and he's prepared even to leave his wife and his kid his child that was just born so I mean those sorts of decisions wouldn't have been taken lightly would they I mean people are called away from their families for various reasons for war and in this case the Buddha felt or the Bodhisattva he would have been then just
just compelled to go and try and work out what was at the core of his deep-seated unhappiness.
And I think when you get to that level, you're really at the sort of an existential level of suffering.
And what I mean by that is questions of why am I alive and why am I conscious?
And in the Buddha's more immediate experiential question, why am I suffering?
why am I suffering couldn't work it out when we do in the evening when we go through these recollections on sickness old age and death you know which refer back to the mythical sort of way that they explain that the Buddha slowly came to awoke really to these factors of life you know seeing somebody who was sick old and die while he was out
in his chariot remember he also sees an ascetic he also sees this ascetic sitting under a tree and that awakens in him is there an escape?
is there a possibility of an escape?
Now just going back a little bit on the psychology of this, remember that because of this deep identity that we have with this life form, with being a human being, there isn't just that side of greed, there isn't just that side of lust and seeking happiness in the sensual world, and indulgence, you can put it all as indulgence or acquisitiveness,
as soon as we've done that remember as soon as we hold on to something we put a sort of fence around it we put a barrier around it and that defines what our pleasures are so anything beyond that boundary becomes unpleasant it becomes something that we don't want or we don't need so our attitude to something which is unpleasant but which is
neither here nor there is to ignore it.
That's what we mean by neutral feelings.
We don't get particularly angry about it, we just don't notice it.
But as soon as these things outside this fence, outside this boundary, begin to look a bit dangerous to us, look as though it's undermining what we own and what we identify with, then you start getting these negative things, aversion,
The pushing away and the anger and the hatred and the spite and all that sort of stuff.
And that all comes under this, there's been some aversion.
And in our meditation, it's boredom.
That's an averse state.
Be bored.
And included in that, remember, is that when these things that seem to be undermining us, seem to be overpowering us, then we start getting this other side of anxiety and fear.
And it all comes down to this basic position of seeking gratification in the world.
And then once we've established in childhood this way of behaving, then you can see how it moves into another layer of psychology when we hit the whole problem of good and evil.
So when we do good and we attach to it, then of course you get into the business, the downside of really using compassion, using love, using sympathetic joy in order to make yourself happy.
So when the other person, for instance, doesn't appreciate what you've done, then you feel hurt, you feel broken, you feel angry.
Things like that, you know, what I've done for you and all that.
And on the other side you've got this fear, sorry, on the other side you've got the evil, evil in the sense of doing what is harmful.
It can be something rather unskillful, which is neither here nor there.
but we're capable of doing great evil you know really doing something which is tremendously harmful both to ourselves and to other beings and then you get into all that other psychology of guilt and shame and remorse and all that and you can see how all this builds up up and up and up until you get you know this massive human suffering stuck in this fathom-long body as the buddha would would call his fathom-long body
And it all begins from this mistake, this unfortunate mistake we make at the beginning of seeking gratification in the world, in the central world.
So all those things are all linked, they're all there, and of course when you suppress them, when you don't push them away, sorry, when you push them away, when you don't want to look at these turbulences, these negative turbulences within us, well that's when they manifest as feelings of depression.
See, depression and, you know, tiredness and lethargy and all that.
All those are, you know, I push them away.
I don't want to see them.
Keep them away.
So when you're meditating, of course, all this starts to come up, doesn't it?
You know, it's like, I think I say on one of the tapes, like lifting a lid off a dustbin.
See, suddenly it all comes up.
So suddenly the depression comes up now, you know, and you've got to see it as a consequence of past conditioning.
See?
you've got to see that actually you know we've manufactured this this isn't come because you know your mother hit you around the ear with a banana when you were three years old or something as you might have done but it's how you reacted to this banana which is which is causing all this problem
Now that doesn't mean to say that childhood is fraught with both ecstatic joy and disaster.
It needn't be that any parent has actually physically or purposefully done you harm.
You can just fall off a bed and it would be a catastrophe which remains as a trauma inside you.
but even so that is that how the child has reacted and there's that continuation of all those things that we learn in childhood throughout life you see until it until we get really bad and then and then we look and we try and find an answer we come to meditation so
when we are when we're meditating you see we're opening the gates we're sort of opening ourselves up to all the stuff that's been suppressed and all that but also from this you know from this understanding we're beginning to see the danger of this wrong relationship we have to the world
And it's seeing that danger, you see, which is painful.
It's hard to sit with it.
It's hard to bear with some of the stuff that comes up.
But there's no other way.
There doesn't seem to be any other way of curing our psychology except in this conscious way.
you know drugs don't help they just suppress they just suppress the physical frame don't they and then you know you feel good but when the drug passes oh it's even worse see there doesn't seem to be I don't know of any of any spiritual practice whereby you don't have to go through this purging you know purgatory the process of purification it's just a matter of fact
But if you understand it as a growth in consciousness, as a growth in wisdom, then you see there's no other way.
Because how else would you know that the gratification is wrong?
How else would you know that there is danger?
How else would you seek the end of suffering?
so if you see your life as more to do with an evolution of wisdom or an evolution of consciousness perhaps the word wisdom is far better actually an evolution of wisdom and not to confuse wisdom with knowledge wisdom is a relationship it's how you relate to the world you're in that's your wisdom
And if you see that that's what you're doing through your meditation is to discover a wiser way of being with the world, then in a sense you're prepared to sort of go through the purgatory.
And also I think when you actually go through the purgatory, when you actually see that it is a process of healing, you're more and more open to actually going through it.
And that's important.
It's important that you actually see that there is gratification and that somehow something goes wrong with that.
And this is what we mean by indulgence, whether it's indulgence in something which is pleasant or indulgence in something which is outwardly unpleasant, like anger.
But it is pleasing to let go of your anger and bang the door and bump somebody on the nose.
That's gratification.
to finally get your own back.
But it's not particularly skillful, it's not really wise.
So it's actually beginning to see that, that we begin to see the path out, you see, and that's the next business of it, the nisarana, the escape.
If there were no escape in the world, then, boy, we'd be miserable, wouldn't we?
And people who get themselves into these dead ends, you know, these, oh, I don't know, these sort of dead ends of the meaninglessness of life, you know.
Or a religious person, I've met a few people who think they're damned.
What do you do?
They're damned.
Now, in Buddhist terms, that's to really believe that there's no escape from samsara.
That whether you like it or not, you'll be reborn and reborn and reborn
first as a shrew in a meditation room and then you get chucked out with a bit of cheese out in a paddock and then you're reborn as a human being picking up a shrew and chucking it out and there's this constant samsara this onward going and in the Buddha's day that was the horror it wasn't ecological disaster it was
It was this thing about having to be reborn and reborn and reborn again.
And there's a lovely conversation in one of the scriptures, I can't remember the details now, where two of the Buddha's cousins, if I remember rightly, decide that, you know, discussing whether to go, whether to actually take up, whether to follow Gautama and take up the robe and bowels.
And the argument goes something like, look, what is life?
You've got to go out there, you've got to plow the ground, you've got to harvest the seed, you've got to eat it, and then you do it again next year, and it's really boring.
And one of them gets really into this and says, yeah, you're right.
And he goes off with the other fellow and says, no, it's for you.
I'm still enjoying this.
So he doesn't leave, you see.
He's still getting something out of the life form.
But it was this fellow who was pointing out to this man who finally leaves how terrible life is in this sort of boring, repetitious way, which I think would have been perhaps more obvious to people in those days, in some ways anyway, because there wasn't this huge entertainment industry.
reminds me of an old pre-war comedian and he's gonna jump he's on a London Bridge and he's gonna jump in and the policeman sees him
and he calls him over you see and they start having this big discussion about life you see as to why suicide and the policeman's arguing you know that life's worth it and the comedian is arguing you know how useless it is you know and the conversation goes on and on and they finally jump both of them jump off the bridges that's brilliant yeah you're right so
This finding of the escape, so that's the Buddha's great thing, isn't it?
And he says that what he's discovered, he's not invented it.
He says this is an ancient path.
He's just rediscovered it.
It's not as though he's the first human being that's ever done it.
He doesn't claim to be that.
In fact, in the mythology of Buddhism, there are Buddhas previous to him.
Going back, I don't know how many times, there are 28 previous Buddhas named in previous huge eons of world systems.
It was just the way that you begin to think when you think of time being cyclic.
I think I mentioned it this morning, that the years just roll over, just keep going, and the whole universe is expanding and then it'll collapse, and then it expands again and collapse.
So there's that idea that this has been going on ever since.
He says that he doesn't see the beginning of karma.
He doesn't see that there is a beginning.
It's always been like this.
And presumably in that sense he doesn't see the end of that process.
but as an individual he found an escape now this escape is not be careful here because this escape as hopefully you've all come to realize in your meditation is not the destruction of the world
There's a very interesting discourse in which somebody asks him, where do the four Mahabhutas come to an end?
Now the four Mahabhutas, the four elements, the four great elements, they are earth, fire, water and air.
And they constitute the physical universe.
So what the person is asking is, where does all this come to an end?
And he says, it's the wrong question.
He says, where do they not find a footing?
It's very interesting.
Where do they not find a footing?
In other words, is there an experience, is there something experiential where you will not find these, but it doesn't deny their existence or destroy them or annihilate them?
and then he goes on to say there is a consciousness which is not touched by the five or six senses so there is a consciousness which is not colored by the six senses so there's no hearing and there's no seeing and there's no there's nothing there there's no thought there's nothing
And yet it is without boundary, and the reason it's without boundary is because there's no phenomena.
You've got to have something to create a boundary.
If there's nothing in this universe, then it's empty space, there's no boundary in it.
It's what we have, it's the things we have that create boundaries for us.
And he says there is this consciousness which is without boundary, and in all directions full of light.
So he's pointing there to an experience which is a total escape from the world.
Now remember that when we say an escape, he's still there.
It's not as though he's disappeared in a puff of smoke and there's just this mystical voice arising from nowhere.
So this escape is not the destruction of anything.
So again, when they ask him, does he believe in any form of annihilation?
He says, no.
He says, everything arises depending on something else and there's no annihilation.
He says, the only things that are annihilated are greed, hatred and delusion.
And greed, hatred and delusion are this way of expressing this wrong relationship we have to the world, which in a psychological sense is this seeking gratification.
And that's what he means by this desire.
When we chant in the morning this tanha, that's what he's referring to.
But remember that there's a completely different psychology and that's the psychology of the Buddha.
That's the psychology of the enlightened beings.
which doesn't have that downer, it doesn't have that gratification it doesn't have all the downers of gratification you know, the grief, the fear, the anger, the frustration all that sort of stuff, it doesn't have that it doesn't have any anger, it doesn't have any fear the fearless one that's one of the epithets of the Buddha he's fearless, what's he afraid of?
there's no connection to the world whereby suffering could arise
how does suffering arise it arises through the connection of attachment identity possession if that's all gone what then is our relationship to the world
What might it be?
So that escape is suggestive of all the teachings of the Buddha concerning the practice which leads us to this point of liberation.
It's an escape.
It's like escaping from prison.
It's like you're finally released.
so now this is where our practice comes in because it's a fundamental practice and what we're learning is not only to see that gratification is wrong because it has these dangers but we're seeing this escape and that's all we're doing we're just seeing where the escape is and the more the escape becomes clearer to us then the more we'll practice because it's like when you see the finishing line you really want to go for it
so even in our practice when we're confused or when we don't think we're getting anywhere or we don't think we're progressing that's a regular one for meditators because you still keep doing these pratfalls and you think well I'm still as I was before you see
so if you have those sorts of feelings those sorts of ideas about yourself remember that all those come from this gratification you're now seeking gratification as it were in the spiritual life meaning you're seeking a certain type of comfort there and that comfort usually comes from the sense of achieving but if you abandon those ideas of trying to achieve anything
and draw that word simply into moment-to-moment mindfulness, then you're always achieving, as long as you're mindful.
You're always here.
And that mindfulness, that sharp mindfulness, is a guard because as we begin to realize, the problem begins or starts with these intentions.
So when we see these intentions and we're awake, we're bright with it, we're not caught up in it, we're not sort of suddenly dashing off and doing something, then that gives us that moment of choice.
And then we begin to see, oh, here's the escape, here's the escape.
And when we access that point within us, which is the observer, so that's not the fullest escape because there's still a sense of me there, but we can see that that's an escape from all the pain that the body might offer us.
because from there we can feel the pain we can see the reaction to pain we can allow the reaction of fear and aversion all that to die away and we can find this equanimity this peacefulness with pain just this patient forbearance and that's an escape it's an escape from all the fear and the anxiety that we have around the body
It's the same with these emotions.
When you distance them, when you can feel them there, rather than being them, it's an escape, isn't it?
You've transcended them.
You're in a different position.
You're not identifying with them.
You're not possessing them.
You're saying, oh, look, there, there's anger.
See, there's grief.
There's depression.
And it's seeing that clearly that we begin to say, oh, here's the escape.
Here's the escape.
That doesn't mean to say at all, does it, that it's easy, it's very difficult in fact, to stay with these mental states as they arise.
But the more we see that this is the escape, the more we'd be happy to stay there.
The more we see it actually as a place where there's healing going on.
And then finally, you know, all this takes a long time.
So there's always going to be that little bit of self left right to the bitter end.
It's not going to let go.
So there's always going to be these pratfalls on the way.
There's always going to be moments when we feel we've slipped back and we're not moving forward and all that.
But we have to keep reminding ourselves that this is an onward going.
This is a long-term commitment.
you know in the Buddhist sense we're talking lifetime not just talking this life so it's a whole process that we're going through so there we have it these three sort of ways of looking at our practice
to be aware of where we're seeking comfort, where we're seeking gratification, to see that greed, that lust, the avarice, we've got lovely, great big words for all that, all centering around the four great lusts, power, riches, fame, to be famous, powerful and rich, everybody wants to do that, that's pretty simple.
And what do you want to be?
I want to be famous, powerful and rich.
And it sends your pleasure.
They're your four main areas, aren't they?
and it's just to see how the mind is constantly moving that way it's always trying to achieve that particular state and that renunciation is the point where we allow that desire to just fade away to just begin to release itself
and as I've pointed out in the morning this you know to let any desire fade away and then just to stay with it long enough to see what the mind is, what the heart is when there's no desire there see that lovely contentment and then with it comes the peace and hopefully you're beginning to experience that even during these times of quiet abiding where we're trying to develop
The more passive side of the factors of enlightenment, the calmness, calmness of the body, just being still, calmness of the heart, stillness of the silence of the mind, all that comes under calmness in a way.
And the attentiveness, just the ability to just be attentive, focused, not particularly focused on any one thing, but just to be here, you know, and to focus on whatever arises and passes away, that sort of very spacious, open awareness.
And the equanimity, just that ability, just the openness to what's coming into our field of awareness.
Okay?
and just every so often to be like that and just to rest within the present moment you see relaxing into the present moment wide awake and then as you do that when it passes you know to ask yourself now what was that like was that a pleasant place to be now fair enough we can get attached to that too and then it becomes and our practice becomes a sort of quietism you know that we're just seeking this lovely quiet place you know leave me alone
Get out of my way.
But then, of course, that's balanced because we then bring in these other factors, the more active factors of the process, which is that interest, the interest of wanting to see, the effort to begin to see things, and the effort to sort of remain at that point of interest and the investigation of the Dhamma.
So, during your day, try to balance those things.
Just go through your day and say, well, this is when I'm practicing this Samatha-type meditation, you know, peaceful abiding, and this is when I'm doing Vipassana.
And get to know yourself.
Know where your weak points are during the day.
Say, well, now here I've got to, you know, I mustn't fall asleep again.
Or here I just let my mind go, you know, I sort of give up effort at this particular point in the day.
And just catch your rhythm, you know, the
they're probably also to do with just the natural rhythms of our bodies you know the circadian rhythms as they call them you know I think that's right isn't it circadian yeah so there's all those rhythms going on too you see so once we've attained once we've got to this to this point of observation then we can see all this happening let's just pause for a moment and
Just whatever thoughts come up, let them come up and pass away.
So, let me encourage you to keep putting in that little bit of effort.
For, you know, Nick and Sarah have been here now for two weeks, you see.
It's sort of coming to the end, so you have to be careful that your energy level doesn't drop, you know.
More like the long-distance runner, you know, like when you see that wire.
You've got to put on that little extra spurt, you know, to get there.
So that's important, you know.
And this is about your fourth day, isn't it, Haji?
So in a sense, hopefully, you'll be more at ease with the schedule, with the regime.
So with that, there's a danger of, well, this is now easier now.
And there's a drop of commitment, a drop of energy.
so you've got to keep lifting it you've got to keep seeing where the effort begins to drop and you just very gently push yourself that's what one of my teachers say push gently and then you'll see the energy comes the energy comes so keep going that's all there is to it may you be liberated sooner rather than later